Guten Morgen die Nuss.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Wusstest du, dass Krypto City so eine Art digitales Mekka ist?
Ja doch die Zentrale ist so ein schwarzer Würfel in der Mitte und alle Daten müssen einmal in ihrem Leben dahin.
Hallo, hier ist Logbuch Netzpolitik, Ausgabe vierundachtzig. Wir schreiben den siebten November zwanzig dreizehn,
Und damit ist ja schon unsere Berichterstatterpflicht fast komplett erfüllt. Oder Linos?
Ja, wir müssen, glaube ich, am Anfang noch kurz äh Ergänzung zur letzten Sendung machen.
Ratum nachschieben.
Ah ihre Datum ist ja jetzt ein großes Wort. Ähm es ähm.
Eine Präzisierung.
Ja genau und zwar ging's um die Glasfasern
die Google nutzt für seine internen Datenbank Replikationen, wo ja dann die NSA drin hing und was ich da äh nicht erwähnt hatte und worauf ich korrekterweise hingewiesen wurde, ist, dass diese Glasfasern
natürlich nicht von Google selber gelegt wurden, sondern von Level drei gemietet werden
und äh dass der Verdacht jetzt also so bei äh eher bei Level drei liegt, dass die der NSA
Zugang gegeben haben. Da gibt's noch eine interessante Entwicklung der letzten Tage. Das ist nämlich der Typ, der quasi für diesen ganzen Kram äh der zumindest intim war, ich weiß jetzt.
Generell für Security zuständig ist. Also
Ja ja, der ist der ist im Security-Team und ähm kann jetzt nicht genau seine äh Berufsbezeichnung sagen, aber er schreibt ja auch, dass er sich mit allem Möglichen rumschlagen muss, aber vor allem eben von Angriffen von außen,
aber dass eben dieser Angriff von innen, das macht sie halt irgendwie fettig und ja. Er wird da recht äh explicit.
Ja, hat gesagt, äh und er sagt halt äh,
sie das System gebaut haben, um Kriminelle rauszuhalten und das äh da innen drin rumzuwühlen, illegal ist, aus guten Gründen. Na ja, aber sorry, ähm.
Da äh bin ich also ich bin da nicht so ganz also ich find's gut, sie nehmen ja jetzt äh sie unternehmen ja jetzt Schritte, um eben da auch den Traffic zu ingrypten, ja. Ähm.
Ich will ihn da jetzt gar nicht äh angreifen, aber ich muss schon sagen, also dass du den,
Du musst natürlich bei deinem Design immer auch daran denken, dass der dass der Angreifer von innen kommen kann und äh innen drin sein kann. Insofern, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist im Prinzip ist das schon mal eine extreme Nachlässigkeit.
Genau und da ich glaube aus der Nummer kommt ja auch nicht raus. Und wenn er sagt, wir wollen hier Kriminelle raushalten, dann ist es halt bei Google,
Sorry, also wenn du das Modelling für Google machst, dann solltest du deinen äh solltest du das nicht nur auf kriminelle äh einschränken. Solltest dir natürlich auch überlegen, wer noch alles Interesse daran hat.
Ja und einfach so korrupte Mitarbeiter ist ja eigentlich so das äh klassische Problem bei Security, dass äh ist auch jenseits dieses NSA-Geheimdienstkontext
Immer wieder, ne, diese Angriffsszenarien, so ja, äh unsere Datenbanken sind ja sicher, wir haben ja eine Firewall, kann ja keiner von außen kommen, aber das ist eigentlich das Nummer eins Problem bei Datensicherheit eben der Missbrauch
interne Missbrauch ist. Das will halt immer keiner so richtig äh sagen, ja, also auch bei diesen ganzen Debatten um deutsche Clouds oder was auch immer,
hilft alles nicht viel in dem Moment wo man halt das Problem intern hat und deswegen muss man sich grundsätzlich auch darüber Gedanken machen wie man eben Daten auch so wenig nutzbar wie möglich,
halten kann, wenn sie überhaupt vorgehalten werden und ja, das ist aber nochmal eine ganz andere Debatte, die führen wir jetzt nicht, denn,
Derzeit werden ja ganz andere Debatten geführt.
Ja, noch ganz kurz, er sagte also, der aller Traffic in diesen NSA-Slides ist jetzt verschlüsselt und die gesamte Arbeit, die NSA darauf aufgewandt hat
den zu verstehen, das muss müssen ja auch nochmal machen, ne? Traffic bekommen ist eine Sache, den dann irgendwie verständlich zu machen. Dieses gesamte Arbeit hat er jetzt äh ruiniert und darüber äh freut er sich und sagt.
Wollen wir jetzt mal gucken, äh wer jetzt da drauf schaut.
Ich meine, was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben jetzt SSL angeschaltet. Das können sie auch knacken. Also.
Ja, kommt eben darauf an, welchen welche Schiffe. Na, okay, müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, aber immerhin. So, sie haben, Google hat schnell reagiert, war angepisst, immerhin, ja? Nein.
Wenn's so schnell geht, frage ich mich natürlich, warum sie das nicht schon immer angeschaltet haben, also tja und jetzt.
Ja, jetzt geht's in wir haben ja äh wir haben ja GroKo, kennst du GroKo?
GroKo.
Ist erstmal vier Jahre GroKo. Große Koalition, habe ich irgendwo letztens gelesen, GroKo.
Furchtbar. Den Namen hasse ich jetzt schon.
Ja ja äh die GroKo äh tritt jetzt in die Woche ja dann.
Die große Koalition der Diditanten, das Krokodil.
Die GroKo, die Krokov, die große Koalitionsverhandlungen treten jetzt in die Phase, ähm,
So die netzpolitischen Entscheidungen dann so zur Treffung ans anstehen und ähm.
Das Wichtigste ist schon durch.
Ja, genau, genau, genau. Dazu kommen wir gleich. Ähm aktueller Diskussionsstand, scheint dort zu sein. Ähm,
jetzt nochmal die Themen durch. Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wir hatten es gesagt so, es gibt jetzt keine äh Partei mit Regierungsbeteiligung, die irgendwie nennenswerten äh nennenswerte Einwände gegen eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat.
Ja, wir erinnern uns auch, die SPD hat ja dann im letzten Jahr schon mal vorgesorgt für diesen großen Koalitionsfall und eine interne Abstimmung über äh die Vorratsdatenspeicherung innerhalb, also innerhalb der SPD
mit allerlei äh Tricks und Machtspielchen so gedreht, dass da eben nichts.
Nichts verabschiedet wurde, was einer CDU missfallen könnte.
Das ist vielleicht echt nochmal ein interessanter Punkt, den könnten wir an der Stelle nochmal wiederholen, weil wie lief das damals genau?
Ja, es gab auch diese interne äh,
wie nennt man das dann bei der SPD, so ein Mitgliedervorschlag, Beschlussfassung, Vorratsdatenspeicherung et cetera, die dann halt vorgelegt wurde und die auch eine gewisse Populismus hatte,
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war das dann am Schluss so, dass für den Parteitag das dann irgendwie gar nicht so richtig behandelt wurde. Da gibt's ja diesen Ausschuss, der äh überhaupt erstmal die
Anträge auswählt, die da beschlossen werden sollen und dabei ist das Ding äh quasi unten runtergefallen und wurde durch so einen Schalen,
Kompromissvorschlag äh des Vorstands glaube ich äh ersetzt, der dann im Prinzip gesagt hat Ulm
also ich erinnere mich
jetzt grad nicht mehr in die Formulierung, aber letztlich war's äh ein Nichtbeschluss. Es war ein äh wir können immer noch tun und lassen, was wir wollen und Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh ja also das Schema der SPD ist ja zu sagen so
Bei uns gibt's ja nur Vorratsdatenspeicherung leid. Ja, weil hier nur mit drei Monaten. Und die,
Generelle Frage dahinter, was ist hier mit der Inkompatibilität,
mit der Gesetzeslage, also vor allem mit der Verfassungs äh Lage, das wird halt dabei genauso ignoriert wie bei der Union generell.
Wir haben's behandelt in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik neununddreißig mit dem schönen die nach oben offene Meisterskala für Grundrechtseinschränkungen. Und die äh ich glaube der die entscheidende,
Passage war dann, dass die SPD sagte, wir stellen klar, ein Abruf für zivilrechtliche Zwecke muss rechtssicher ausgeschlossen werden,
Okay? Und die nach äh Rechtsgrundlage für eine Vorratsspeicherung erhobenen Daten dürfen nicht zur Erstellung eines Bewegungsprofits abgefragt werden, ja? Ähm das war dann so ihre,
Äh ihre Kern äh Position zur ähm zur Vorzeit sprechen. Ah ja, sie wollten die Speicherfrist natürlich auf deutlich unter sechs Monate einschränken. Deutlich.
Und ähm na ja.
Anders gesagt, sie wollen auch speichern.
Sie wollen speichern, genau.
Und genau dieses die Dauer scheint so ist der Flurfunk scheint jetzt das Diskussion die Diskussionsgrundlage oder der Diskussionspunkt zu sein in den Koalitionsverhandlungen die da stattfinden in der Unterarbeitsgruppe digitale Agenda
ja? Und die sitzen also jetzt am Tisch und sagen, ja, was ist denn so jetzt so eine, was ist denn jetzt grundrechtsschonender oder was, ne.
Also sagen wir mal, sie werden sich einfach auf drei Monate einigen. Da kann die SPD sagen, dass sie ja ihre Forderungen voll durchgesetzt hat und der Union ist es am Ende egal.
Weil äh für sie spielt es, glaube ich, nicht so eine große Rolle, ob's nur drei, sechs oder neun Monate sind. Hauptsache, das Ding kommt, wohlwissend, dass, wenn's erstmal da ist, äh die Dauer beim nächsten Vorfall,
der drei Monate und ein Tag zurücklag äh ein hochsetzen können so, ja wir hätten sie ja finden können, aber wir haben ja einen Tag vorher die Daten der bösen Terroristen löschen müssen
Weil die böse SPD äh hat ja gesagt, nur drei Monate und mit der Union wäre das nicht passiert. So und dann fünf Jahre später,
passiert dann halt was. Ein halbes Jahr und so weiter, ja.
Ja, der entscheidende Punkt ist hier natürlich wieder den ähm,
ja, die, die, wie nennt man das, den Damm einfach zu brechen? Und wenn du dann erstmal Vorratsseitensprechung hast, dann kannst du halt auch länger und kürzer, äh, länger machen, wie du willst, länger, immer kürzer, immer. So, das ist äh,
man das so kennt, ja. Also hier wird dann nochmal was auf uns zukommen.
Genau, kennen wir schon, alt.
Ja, na ja, bis jetzt, ich meine.
Erinnere mich damals, ja, Argumentation ist alles, stimmt. So, aber ich erinnere mich äh an das Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil und so, ne? Also ich ich,
Es ist hier dieser Punkt, Argumentation ist alt und irgendwann wird äh vergrätzt du damit ja auch die Leute, ne. Irgendwann gibst du halt einfach auf und sagt, komm, dann macht eure scheiß Vorseitensprechung, Hauptsache, wir haben ähnlich Ruhe von euch Arschlöchern, ihr gebt eh keine.
Nächstes Thema Breitbandausbau, kurzes Thema, kennt man ja. Wir machen Breitbandausbau,
Jetzt ist das bei der Arbeitsgruppe Wirtschaft angelegt und im Moment spricht man von mindestens fünfzig Megabit pro Sekunde sollen bis zweitausendachtzehn in Deutschland Standard sein. Sagt aber keiner, ob die jetzt von äh ausm Kabel oder aus äh aus einer aus einer Antenne kommen sollen.
Ähm,
Und na ja, innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre wäre das für meine Eltern eine Verfügzigfachung der Bandbreite. Äh bin ich mal gespannt, ja? Das ist also der dieser typische.
Fehlt noch viel mehr, da fehlt in welche Richtung fünfzig Megabit? Ja, wir wissen alle, was gemeint ist. Sie reden also hier von VDSL, dann,
Wie viele Stunden pro Monat kann ich äh die Daten äh in dieser Geschwindigkeit senden, bevor Drossel äh daherkommt. Und dann,
Zwanzigachtzehn, fünfzig Megabit. Ja, ich meine, in, in, in, in anderen Ländern kriegst du kriegst du Entschuldigungsschreiben von deinem ISP.
Dir kein Gigabit geben.
Dir kein Gigabit geben können innerhalb von äh fünf Tagen und äh in diesem Land redet man ernsthaft über äh solche lächerlichen äh Geschwindigkeiten als Ziel, von denen wir jetzt schon wissen, dass sie die noch nicht mal erreichen werden
Weil das einfach in dem derzeitigen Modell überhaupt nicht
drin ist. Wie wollen sie das überhaupt beschleunigen, wenn sie keine Liberalisierung vornehmen und die Telekom da einfach mal äh vom Futtertrog äh wegziehen
woran sie kein Interesse haben, weil sie selber Eigentümer sind der Telekom und aus ihren Gewinnen natürlich auch immer ihr Startsäckel gefüllt bekommen. Das ist doch einfach alles komplett absurd,
Also äh ich halte davon wenig. Äh ich finde es schön, dass sie das Thema an sich überhaupt schon mal behandeln, also so einem das Gefühl geben,
dass das irgendwie äh eine Rolle spielt, aber genau das ist ja auch nichts Neues und äh mit solchen Forderungen machen sie sich meiner Meinung nach einfach lächerlich. Da ist einfach keine Agenda, da ist kein keine Vision, da ist kein,
wenn man heute über Zukunft redet, dann sagt man einfach, bis zwanzig zwanzig hat hier jeder ein Gigabit,
Und dann sagen alle, wie, aber das ist ja total schwierig. Und dann sagt man, ja und es war genauso schwierig,
wie die Amerikaner irgendwie es schwierig fanden, zum Mond zu fliegen und wir fliegen jetzt hier auch einfach mal zum Mond, indem wir einfach Glasfaser überall reinlegen. Und dann wird äh,
Jede Öffnung des Bodens in Deutschland einfach auch noch von Glasfaser begleitet. Das ist einfach so. Und dann gehört es einfach dem Staat. Und dann wird da einfach so lange die Daten äh durchgepumpt bis äh.
Bisher noch mehr Glaskuchen. Ja, es ist.
Ja. Das ist nun wirklich echt keine begrenzte Ressource, aber es macht mich irre.
Also Breitbandausbau ja da also sich überhaupt einzubilden, dass man da als Regierung irgendwie großartig was zu zu sagen hätte, ist schon.
Wahrscheinlich machen sie nur deshalb fünfzig Megabit, weil sie äh von BND gesagt bekommen haben, dass sie nicht mehr abgehört bekommen. Na ja, oh Mann, das macht mich wahnsinnig.
Dazu kommen wir später. Ja, das ist äh.
Zickig macht mich das. Aber ich bin schon wieder ruhig. Wir sollen ja nicht aufgeregt diskutieren.
Dann wird gesagt, sie wollen die Störerhaftung abbauen, ja? Wir erinnern uns, äh Störerhaftung ist das Problem, dass äh dazu führt, dass ich kein freies WLAN an meine Nachbarn geben kann
sondern das irgendwie durch einen VPN oder durch Torwerfen muss, damit ich nicht eventuell als Störer zu ihren ähm.
Zu ihrem Missetaten im Internet äh als herangezogen werde und dann dafür hafte, wenn die also beispielsweise was aus dem Internet,
runterladen oder sich an äh oder hochladen, was äh irgendwelche, irgendwelche Menschen Gefühle verletzt. Ähm wäre ich in der Verantwortung. Wir erinnern uns, da gibt's,
der jetzt multiple Fälle,
von Rentnern, die gar nicht wussten, dass es Internet gibt und äh plötzlich dann irgendwelche Abmahnungen bekommen haben, weil äh irgendwelche Nachbarskinder dann Lady Gaga äh Torent gemacht haben oder sowas,
prinzipiell Störerhaftung abzuschaffen ist also ist ein sehr viel größerer,
Ein sehr viel besserer, sinnvoller und größerer Schritt in so eine digitale Gesellschaft? Also ich würde, ich biete ja jetzt schon ein, ein freies WLAN zu Hause an,
äh würde das auch natürlich sehr gerne nicht durch äh durch VPN und oder Tor äh piepen müssen und hätte auch kein ähm kein Problem damit, meinen Internetanschluss zu teilen, insbesondere unter in der Hoffnung, dass das äh viele andere eben auch machen.
Ja? Ähm das ist also wäre eine sehr sinnvolle Sache. Ähm.
Aber es gibt da keine Details dazu. Wir erinnern uns, dass es da einen ähm Gesetzesvorschlag, Gesetzesentwurf vom,
vereint digitale Gesellschaft gibt,
zum Copy und eingeladen hat, aber ehrlich gesagt bin ich bis jetzt nicht besonders zuversichtlich, dass die Bundesregierung auch daran denkt, den einfach zu nutzen
weil der wäre ja jetzt wasserdicht und ähm das wäre ja unter Umständen äh blöd für die,
Ähm dann wurde.
Kam zu, zu Ohren, dass die Bundesregierung äh die zukünftige Bundesregierung sich gegen diese Zwangsinitiative ähm.
Äh wenden möchte. Da geht's um das Thema äh wir hatten das vor einigen Folgen besprochen, dass der äh dass die Netzbetreiber jetzt ganz gerne den Router zum Netzabschlusspunkt äh,
erklären würden
um damit äh beispielsweise zu verhindern, dass der Nutzer einfach ein anderes äh Router-Endgerät bei sich betreiben kann. Äh ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Folge das war, das war eine interessante Debatte. Ich würde das deshalb nicht nochmal wiederholen wollen
ähm.
Hm
Sondern verweise stattdessen auf äh einerseits die Sendung und andererseits die Stellungnahme des CCC, die da jetzt auch vor ein paar Tagen zu veröffentlicht wurde.
So, kopiere ich da jetzt mal rein den Link.
Ja, äh das war die Ausgabe Nummer achtzig digitaler Klimawandel. Ähm das Kapitel,
Bundesnetzagentur Anhörung zu Zwangsratern und da haben wir das auch nochmal etwas filigraner aufgeteilt was man eigentlich bei so einem Rauter eigentlich an Stufen unterscheiden müsste,
Das ist sehr wohl ein Teil, wo man die Argumentation der Provider nachvollziehen kann, ne?
Modem, Firma Update, et cetera, aber eben auch ein Teil, der einfach auch explizit zur eigenen digitalen Souveränität gehört und von daher auch grundrechtsrelevant ist,
Ihr wisst schon, dieses Grundrecht, was bisher noch so recht keinen interessiert hat, aber was es nichtsdestotrotz äh gibt
nämlich das mit der Integrität der eigenen äh Infrastruktur, was an dieser Stelle sicherlich auch ähm.
Berührt werden würde. Insofern fände ich das auch mal sehr interessant, wenn so eine Entscheidung zu Zwangsratern käme,
Also für Zwangsratter käme, ob das dann äh nicht auch mal äh im Hinblick auf dieses Grundrecht,
Verfassungsgericht abgeklopft werden könnte, denn da sehe ich auf jeden Fall.
Hebel.
Ja, also meine Iran, aber wissen schon.
Dann hört man Netzzentraität wollen sie auf jeden Fall. Sind sich aber noch nicht ganz klar darüber,
Äh ob's jetzt per Gesetz oder per Verordnung sein soll und ähm,
da ist natürlich davor zu warnen, also bei bei dem bei der Frage der Netzneutralität sehen wir ja die Entwicklung, dass,
Etwas als Netzneutralität bezeichnet wird, was es de facto nicht ist. Dass man sagt,
Wir machen, wir definieren ein ein Internet, das gibt's jetzt,
und das ist gut und zusätzlich zum Internet kann man einen Manageservice machen und das ist dann eben kein Internet und deswegen ist das ist das Internet dann noch Netzneutralität. Äh herrscht im Internet Netzneutralität. Das ist, wie gesagt, ähm,
ich glaube, das wurde auch hier in Sendung schon ausreichend behandelt. Das Entscheidende ist, in dem Moment, wo ich zwei Klassen definiere, ist es eben nicht mehr neutral. Ja, ich kann gerne sagen, bei mir sind innerhalb der ersten Klasse, sind alle gleich,
ähm,
Aber es gibt dann eben noch eine zweite Klasse, ja? Und dann gibt es eben Diskriminierung. Ja, und das kann man auch sagen, die einen sitzen vor dem Bus, die anderen sitzen hinten, es bleibt Diskriminierung.
Und es hilft nicht zu sagen, innerhalb ihrer Rasse, Klasse äh oder sonst was, sind die Menschen gleich, nein, sie ähm ist oder die Datenpakete, billiger Datenpakete inzwischen schon echt Menschenrechte.
Wollen sie denn wir behandeln sie doch genauso schlecht wie alle anderen Ausländer. Ja. Ja.
Vielen Dank. Damit haben wir das Thema, glaube ich, äh aus eindrücklich äh.
Genau.
So da, da aber die Gefahr ist eben, wenn man an etwas Netznotalitätsverordnung dranschreibt, was keine ist. Das ist natürlich so der geschickteste Schachzug, den man machen kann, weil wenn dann noch einer sagt, ey, wir brauchen Netznetralität, dann sag mal, bist du doof? Wir haben hier die Verordnung.
Innenminister, oh je.
Alter. Also.
Es tauchte dann ein ein internes Papier des Innenministeriums auf.
Dieses interne Papier war zwar angefertigt und äh zu Ende geschrieben, aber das war ja noch gar nicht freigegeben. Das sollte ja so noch gar nicht öffentlich werden. Wahrscheinlich, weil irgendeiner dem Friedrich geflüstert hat,
Guck mal Zeitung. Und da standen dann so schöne Sachen drin wie, ja, wir müssen hier auf jeden Fall Videoüberwachung ausweiten.
Wie ja Frau Merkel schon vor ein paar Jahren sagt, wenn man das machen kann, dann muss das auch gemacht werden.
Und ähm,
Wir müssen wieder, wir müssen Telekommunikationsüberwachung äh ähm ausweiten. Wir erinnern uns, Telekommunikationsüberwachung ist Staatstrojaner.
Und dann haben sie, steht da auch noch drin, ja und wir müssen, da wird's jetzt spannend, vor allem in, im, im Bezug auf die ähm.
Auf die äh auf die auf die zukünftig abgelöste Störerhaftung. Sagen sie, ja ähm wir würden gerne den Datenverkehr im Internet ähm,
besser überwachen können. Und da würden wir gerne eine Zielpersonen spezifische Ausleitung bei offenen und geteilten Netzen,
vornehmen können. In Klammern ein Großteil der Datenverkehr,
Wird ja hierzulande über äh wichtige Infrastrukturknoten des Netzes geleitet und das ist weitgehend unabhängig vom konkreten Internetzugang oder der geographischen Ansiedlung des genutzten Dienstanbieters. Mit anderen Worten,
es gibt irgendwie einen großen Internetknoten, da hängt der BND dran,
und ähm ich marschiere mit meinem mit meinem Computer vom Metaebene WLAN in das äh was weiß ich, Vodafone, Datennetz
in das WLAN meines Arbeitgebers, das wieder bei einem anderen Anbieter ist und dann wieder in Mainz und das äh,
ist natürlich mit Schwierigkeiten verbunden, wenn man sagt, man macht die Auswertung anhand der IP-Adresse. Wenn der Schnorchel aber einfach mal mitguckt
was denn so für Cookies da drauf sind. Was zum Beispiel alle zehn Minuten für E-Mail abgeholt wird, ja? Einfach nur zu welchen
E-Mails verwand ich mich verbinde, ist ein weltweit ähm einzigartiger Fingerabdruck meines Rechners. So, ich brauche überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen sage ich auch immer allen Leuten, es ist nicht sinnvoll, allen Traffic durch Tor zu leiten. Du verlierst garantiert deine Anonymität. Ja, das nur am Rande. In dem Moment, wo ich ähm,
wo ich irgendwo meinen Rechner hier aufklappe, geht der hin und verbindet sich zu, Moment, ich schaue mal eben, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn verschiedenen E-Mail-Servern,
Ähm das sollte glaube ich ein ausreichende, ausreichendes Merkmal sein.
Was hast du mehr E-Mail-Server als ich oder was?
Ich habe eine ganze Menge E-Mail-Server. Nee, keiner davon, einer davon gehört mir selber. So, ähm.
Ähm.
Ne, dass dann sowas bei wie Arbeitgeber ähm.
Computerclubs äh und sowas, ja und damit ist das ist das Thema äh.
Also dieses dieser Neusprech ist wirklich geil. Zielpersonen spezifische Ausleitung. Also im Victory steht Ausleitung noch nicht, ja, Ausleitung.
Also das ist sozusagen mal wieder so ein Alternativwort für äh Überwachung.
Auswertung. Das andere Wort, was wir in der letzten Sendung hatten, war ja auffangen, ne? Das war der Begriff der äh.
Ja, genau, die Daten wurden ja aufgefang.
Die fallen denen auf den Kopf.
Da haben wir, da haben wir gar nicht drüber gesprochen, oder? Ist uns danach erst klar äh geworden, also diese.
Kommunikation wurden aufge.
Fünfhundert Millionen Kommunikation, die der BND gemacht hat, die werden ja gar nicht woanders angefallen, sondern die wären ja vom BND,
aufgefangen worden und also dieses Sterntalerbild, das ist also wirklich hammerharter Neusprech,
Ja, also der BND, wie so ein kleines Mädchen auf der Blumenwiese nachts im Wald, springt umher und sammelt die Daten, die einfach flockig, leuchtend so vom Himmel herabfallen. Ja, also ist einfach äh schön.
Ganz viele Daten und teilt ihn mit seinen Freunden.
Oh Mann.
Datenverkehr im Internet sehr viel besser abschneid.
Ausleitung.
Wir reden hier von den berühmten zwanzig Prozent, ne? Und es klingt da natürlich nach einer Erhöhung dieser berühmten zwanzig Prozent. Man könnte argumentieren, dass sie hier,
schon seit längerem das machen, was in den USA als Ex-KeyScore bekannt ist und das im Nachhinein ähm legalisieren wollen. Wir erinnern uns
Grade in Deutschland hat bis jetzt ja noch keiner, der dokumentierten fünfundzwanzig Abgehörten.
Provider sagen können, wie das geschieht. Freunde, es ist der Internetknotenpunkt,
und da äh sitzt der BND und hat sehr gute Fähigkeiten. Und dann sagt die SPD in diesem äh äh Koalitionsverhandlung, ey äh hier Idee, wir sind dagegen
und dann sagen die wird irgendwie einen Tag nach der Meldung, wird äh,
nach der Meldung, sie wollen Internet äh in diesem Stile abhören, wird dann gesagt, äh nee, doch nicht, haben wir uns anders überlegt.
Technische Verständnisfrage.
Wenn man das und in dich äh entschuldigen, nicht dass äh das Detzigs. Ja, das. Ja, ja.
Ist die Domainvergabestelle, nee für die Hörer jetzt, die sind ja alle.
Also der Austausch also beliebige Peering Points, da wo Provider sozusagen Daten austauschen. Wenn man davon an ausgehen kann, dass es mit denen eigentlich genauso ist,
wie innerhalb von Google. Ja und Google kann sozusagen jetzt von innen durch das äh ableuchten oder ausleiten von Licht äh quasi mitgeschnitten werden,
wäre es nicht vielleicht auch mal eine interessante Strategie, dass auch diese Peerings voll verschlüsselt stattfinden.
Das ist ein äh sehr.
Was sollte zwei Provider davon abhalten oder auch N Provider davon abhalten,
äh in diese äh Technologie zu investieren, die zumindest diesen Austausch untereinander mal verschlüsselt macht, dass wenn man zu Provider B äh geht, dann halt den Kiefern B nimmt,
Nur auf so einem kurzen Wege. So, ich meine, existiert dieser Hardware, ist das leistbar in diesen Datenmengen, äh kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass nicht.
In der inzwischen von mir so oft in Folge des Chaos-Radius, die ich gar nicht so gut fand, äh als wir sie gemacht haben, wo äh Andi Müller Magun der Erdgeist und ich äh zu Gast waren,
ziemlich genau das vorgeschlagen.
Na ja. Ich habe die leider nicht äh gehört. Welche war das?
Ich suche sie jetzt auch nochmal raus. Also inzwischen.
Radioaktive Krypto-Party oder.
Oh, war das, oh, haben die denn so einen bescheuerten Namen gegeben oder war das.
Nee, das ist mit Nebler, ja, ja und davor war die großen Brüder, das war nämlich die mit Andy, ja. So, die die radioaktive Kryptoparty war, genau.
Die großen Bruder, alles klar. Na ja, mhm. Nimm's mal mit in die Links rein, CR eins, neun, eins.
So, die kann ich kann man die Sendung kann man vor allem deshalb empfehlen, weil der äh habe ich auch schon jetzt mehrmals wiederholt empfohlen. Ähm,
weil der Andy Müller Magun da sehr ähm sehr viele interessante und wichtige Dinge sein und das Aufnahmedatum ist da der siebenundzwanzigste Sechste
und äh da tun sich seherische Fähigkeiten auf. Im Prinzip
es ist die Sendung alles was vor vier Monaten aufgenommen immer noch alles was zu der ganzen NSA Angelegenheit jemals zu sagen war ist nichts neues mehr dazu gekommen
Na ja, genau.
Ich habe sie auch äh gehört, aber ich habe mich jetzt an die Aussage von Erdgeist nicht erinnert, aber interessant,
Chaos-Radiosendung haben wir ohnehin äh ziemlich syrische Qualitäten. Es gibt da auch noch eine Ausgabe von vor zehn Jahren, wo Frank im Prinzip,
Szenario auch schon relativ klar in Aussicht gestellt hat. Es ist wirklich erschreckend.
Sehr Qualitäten werden im weiteren Verlauf der Sendung noch äh gewürdigt werden,
Auf jeden Fall kam dann raus, äh ja, wir wollen hier Datenverkehr im Internet überwachen und dann merkte man, oh komm, gar nicht so gut an und dann wurde kam kurz darauf die Meldung, ach nee, doch nicht.
Und gestern war dann, glaube ich, so die wurde der ganzen dann die Kröne Krone aufgesetzt, als,
diesem Innen ähm Ministeriumspapier äh der Gedanke entfleuchte, ja, wir haben ja jetzt so ein Mautsystem und wir haben ja damals äh überall auf die Autobahn Brücken gebaut
Über die Autobahnbrücken gebaut, die Kennzeichen fotografieren,
um Mautabrechnungen zu machen, ja? Und jetzt könnten wir doch einfach mal damit jedes Kennzeichen fotografieren, nicht nur das von LKWs und,
genau, also tu sie ohnehin,
Und jetzt wäre das doch mal an der Zeit, wo die Daten ja schon da sind, ne?
Oder lasst mich anders formulieren. Lasst uns doch mal das tun, wovon wir vor bei der Einführung gesagt haben, dass wir das auf gar keinen Fall jemals tun werden.
Und zwar diese Mautstation zur Überwachung nutzen. Ähm.
Und auch nochmal diese Unterscheidung. Das ist, glaube ich, auch äh viel nicht unbedingt klar,
Technisch ist es halt nicht so, dass nur LKWs dort äh fotografiert und ausgewertet werden, sondern erst,
Wenn das Nummernschild quasi analysiert wurde, weiß man, dass es sich hierbei nicht um einen äh LKW handelt, das heißt, es wird ohnehin äh alles schon mal erfasst und es wird auch alles geprüft und danach wird es vergessen.
Und äh da man hier sozusagen aktiv vergessen muss, ja
ist eigentlich diese Information, die man haben will, ohnehin schon da und Teil des Systems. Also ich wäre noch nicht mal überrascht, wenn wir irgendwie irgendwann in den nächsten
Wochen, Monaten oder Jahren äh sozusagen auf einmal die Information bekommen mit äh ach übrigens haben wir sowieso schon gedacht.
Danach riecht das doch auch. Also äh natürlich war werden die Mautstationen so genutzt.
Rückwirkende Legalisierung.
Rückwirkende Legalisierung ist genau das gleiche wie mit dem mit dem äh Internetknotenpunkte abhören. Ja? Kommen wir gleich kommen wir,
Kommen wir gleich nochmal zu, weil ich dem eigenes eigenes Thema geregnet habe. Aber merken wir uns der BRD und die Internetknotenpunkte abhören. Da passiert relativ offensichtlich ähm mehr als das, was wir bisher wissen, denn äh schon vor Jahren
äh
lobte oder bewunderte, dass äh der Geheimdienst der Briten die Fähigkeiten des BND
in der Internetüberwachung. Kommen wir gleich aber nochmal zu, ja? Also das, was da als Papier aus dem Innenministerium kommt, das riecht sehr nach ähm.
Das riecht sehr nach ähm nach, wir machen das mal rückwirkend legal, was unsere Geheimdienste hier machen. Ähm,
Außerdem, und das, das war dann nur so eine Meldung, die habe ich auch, also ich meine, innerhalb eines Tages, ja, kommt wird gesagt, hier äh,
Friedrich Willi will die Autobahn überwachen mit einer Infrastruktur, die ohnehin keinen anderen Zweck hat, als Autos zu überwachen, weil Geld verdienen konnte man mit der Maut ja relativ offenbar nicht. Ähm.
Deswegen also innerhalb eines Tages,
Diese Schlagzeile? Friedrich will Autobahn überwachen und innerhalb des gleichen Tages kommt die Schlagzeile, nee doch nicht.
Irgendwie.
Ja, da wird einfach mal der Fuß ins Wasser gehalten, so.
Da wird der Fuß ins Wasser gehalten und ich ich habe da jetzt viel drüber nachgedacht. Du bist als als Politiker, du bist.
Du musst ähm du bist ein gewissen Taktieren ausgesetzt, ne? Du hast irgendwie deine eigene Partei, die du irgendwie dir warm halten musst, äh die muss dich irgendwie wieder wählen, die muss das Vertrauen in dich halten, ne? Du musst dich, musst dich auch gegen
deine Widersache innerhalb der Partei irgendwie wehren können. Du hast aber auch ähm.
Deine äh du hast irgendwie die Medien, die irgendwie über dich schreiben, die so deine öffentliche
Öffentlichkeit irgendwie machen, das heißt die schränken irgendwie deinen Handlungsspielraum sehr stark ein, weil sie, weil sie irgendwie wie so ein Korrektiv funktionieren, dich aber auch teilweise in, in, in, in, in Dinge treiben können, die du vielleicht nicht willst,
Ähm du hast da irgendwo noch so ein WLAN und in all diesen du hast dann die anderen Parteien,
die mit dir um um die Gunst der Wähler und der Medien äh
konkurrieren und in all diesen musst du am Ende auch noch eine irgendwie eine halbwegs vernünftige Entscheidung treffen. Ja, während die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Lobbyisten für ihre Interessen bei dir an der Tür stehen und klopfen und dich davon überzeugen, dass äh dass du jetzt der einzige Mensch bist, der ein Weltuntergang verhindern kann, ne. Dieser dieser Beruf hat schon
ähm eine sehr hohe Anforderung an an einen Menschen und es ich denke, es ist relativ.
Also es gibt eigentlich nur noch zwei Optionen, die relativ offenbare ist, dass der Friedrich diesem gesamten Gefüge in keiner Form gewachsen ist.
Ähm.
Das kann aber auch sein.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass er das äh besser ist als jeder andere jemals zuvor. Und ähm,
Ich habe eigentlich bis jetzt immer nur ähm bis jetzt habe ich die die habe ich,
Gefahr in Politikern immer nur dann gesehen, wenn sie ähm intelligent waren. Ja, also wenn sie gerissen waren. Zum Beispiel in Ursula von der Leyen Chao ist, ist große Gefahr zu sehen. Die Frau ist nicht doof
ja? Ähm,
die kann ähm es sich für auch für nichts zu schade. Gutenberg, in dem ist, ist groß, große Gefahr zu sehen. Ist ein richtig äh gerissenes, gerissenloses äh Wesen. Ähm.
Und bei dem Friedrich bin ich mir irgendwie nicht ganz sicher. Also in dem ist,
Auf jeden Fall auch große Gefahr zu sehen, weil er mit einer hohen Verantwortung äh betraut ist. Und mein ich mein Eindruck ist, dass er dieser Verantwortung nicht gewachsen ist. Ähm es könnte aber auch echt sein, dass er diesen Eindruck irgendwie absichtlich vermittelt,
Äh ich bin da äh ich bin äh wie gesagt, ich ich handle, ich ich,
Ich denke, irgendwie eigentlich von seinem Handeln würde ich sagen, dass er nicht zurechnungsfähig ist. Ähm aber.
Ich kann mir andererseits nicht vorstellen, dass das jemand, dass das jemand dulden würde, ja? Also.
Das ist überhaupt erstmal die Frage.
Bescheuert wär, dann müssten seine würden seine Mitarbeiter denen irgendwann sagen, ey pass mal auf. Komm bitte.
Mal, aber es ist ja auch überhaupt nicht gesagt, dass der Innenminister bleibt. Weil äh die äh Ministerien müssen erst noch ausgehandelt werden. Die SPD wird sicherlich
äh sich nicht mit zu wenig zufrieden geben, ja?
Und ähm da steht das Außenministerium, da steht das Innenministerium, da steht das Finanzministerium, also zwei von diesen drei äh
Werden sie sich sicherlich äh einverleiben wollen. Sicherlich hat die CDU am Innenministerium gewisser Hinsicht ein größeres Interesse und kann das dann auch vielleicht durchsetzen. Müsste das dann aber auch,
teuer bezahlen. Ich sag's nur. Also.
Ja ja, also schauen wir.
Offen, ne? Also auch nicht klar, ob Friedrichs unbedingt bleiben würde, nä?
Ja, dass das stimmt. Ähm er machte dann nur.
Gerade wenn das Finanzministerium der SPD geopfert werden müsste, bräuchte Schäuble ja einen neuen Job.
Und Innenminister hatte der ja schon mal, ob er unbedingt Bock äh hat auf den Job, weiß ich nicht,
gewisser Hinsicht sieht er sich ja, glaube ich, äh jetzt da auch äh am Olymp angekommen. Also alles außer Bundeskanzler in, also Finanzminister ist sozusagen,
äh einzige Ministerium, was eben auch noch.
Über alle anderen hinweg äh Entscheidungen durchsetzen kann. Alle müssen mit ihm klarkommen und so weiter ist von daher eine ein.
Relativ mächtige Position.
Mächtige und äh von daher dankbare Position.
Ich bin.
Ja, also ich hätte gerne, ich weiß nicht, ob ich sagen würde, ich hätte lieber einen intelligenten äh Innenminister, weil der dann eben auch eine sehr viel größere Gefahr darstellen kann, wenn er sein, wenn er irgendwie seine
Taten äh auch noch mit mit einer mit einem intelligenten Ansatz irgendwie versucht zu begehen. Also ich kann das nicht sagen, aber
Es macht mir wirklich große Sorgen, dieser Friedrich, dem also es ist wirklich, wirklich ich fürchte mich,
davor, dass was der was der Mann mit welcher Macht dieser Mann im Prinzip ausgestattet ist. Da kann viel schiefgehen,
Ähm zum Beispiel hat er jetzt gesagt, äh ja, wir wollen jetzt ähm einen IT-Sicherheitsgesetz machen und wir wollen jetzt das Internet quasi per Gesetz sicher machen,
So das äh ging's dann irgendwie darum, Datenverkehr ausschließlich über europäische Netze zu leiten äh oder sonstwas, ja. Also jetzt,
Gut, da braucht man, glaube ich, gar nichts zu sagen, dass das eh ein Schuss in den Ofen. Ähm,
Was noch diskutiert wird, ist äh die Idee eines internetministers oder eines ständigen Ausschusses für die digitale Gesellschaft,
Hier in der äh Bundestag hat ja immer Ausschüsse, ne? Ich kenne jetzt nur irgendwie Justizausschuss und Rechtsausschuss, aber es gibt sicherlich noch mehr.
Ich glaube, die digitale Gesellschaft würde sich über so einen Dauerausschuss durchaus freuen.
Ja, es, es, es gibt ja dann, es gibt ja den Unterausschuss neue Medien, äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und ähm offensichtlich überlegen sie halt, gibt es so Erwägungen.
Netzpolitik sozusagen zu promoten und von unter Ausschuss auf Ausschuss-Level äh zu heben. Ja, ja. Und das ist sicherlich äh ein Minimum eigentlich.
Internetminister, ja?
Aber, und jetzt kommen, entschließt sich der Kreis zu unserem schönen Mitgliederbegehren äh in der in der SPD zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da gab es jetzt irgendwie so eine Sendung von, was war das? Stern oder sowas, ne?
TV, ja. Oder nee, das fand ich äh eine von Sternen äh organisierte Panelgeschichte, wo es auch ein Mitschnitt äh online gibt.
Und da äußerte sich dann.
Sigmar Gabriel gegenüber einer Frau in in also in einer Art, das ist wirklich, das muss man gesehen haben, wie er da so sitzt und
also wie absolut herablassend der allein schon anspricht, es ist sehr erstaunlich
sehr erfreut, also sehr interessant sollte man gesehen haben und äh unterhält sich dann so über die äh,
Diese linksintellektuelle Berliner Internetwelt, die mit den ähm.
Realität da draußen nicht zu tun hat.
Die mit der Realität da draußen nichts zu tun hat. Und da gibt's dann 'ne.
Ja, ganz ausführliche Reaktionen, die also auch zeigen, dass diese intellektuelle berliner Internetwelt ähm,
Alles andere als irgendwie äh eine eine ökonomische Elite des Landes fährt, sondern sehr viel mehr den äh den ähm
dem prekären Verhältnissen des Arbeitsmarktes unterworfen ist und ja. Ich will mich da gar nicht, also es.
Die Bewertung äh dessen, was er da gesagt hat und wie er es gesagt hat, halte ich für schwierig, da kann man jetzt alles Mögliche äh reindeuten. Das ist natürlich auch einfach Ausdruck eines äh grundsätzlichen
des Kurses, der so langsam in Wallung kommt, ja, also beide Seiten im Sinne von
traditionelle, politische Ausrichtung und dann äh neue nutzpolitische äh Ansätze,
die beiden Seiten merken, äh jeder für sich, dass man, um voranzukommen, sich mehr mit dem anderen auseinandersetzen muss,
Ne, ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, für die nitzpolitische Bewegung auch, sagen wir mal so,
Punkt, an dem man jetzt angekommen ist. Das hatten wir jetzt bei der Diskussion über die Demo et cetera hat natürlich auch das Wahlergebnis klang das ja auch schon durch, also dass man sozusagen mit den Mitteln, äh die bisher eingesetzt wurden, zwar vielleicht weit gekommen ist, aber sicherlich nicht weit genug
genauso äh wird er auch in einem anderen äh Feld gerudert und das sind dann eben,
ausdrücke, ja? Ich meine, es gab dann wieder äh ja,
Ja, diese öffentliche Austriterei, nach den Piraten geht es jetzt halt wieder bei der SPD los. Ich atme da immer etwas äh schwer, ja? Ich meine, was hast du dir, was hast du gedacht, ja, äh,
was man da bewegen kann äh in dem Laden.
Ja, das ist äh.
Dann vielleicht auch einfach die falsche Anspruchshaltung an der Stelle. Ich weiß es nicht. Will das auch gar nicht weiter bewerten, aber,
das ist, glaube ich, jetzt nicht so relevant für diese GroKo, die Geschichte.
Prinzipiell sagt der ähm,
sagte Sigmar Gabriel und da hat er ja auch recht mit, dass es einen großen Teil Menschen in diesem Lande gibt, die,
sehr viel konkretere Sorgen in ihrem Leben haben, als Netzpolitik, weil sie existenziell bedroht sind.
Das ist so sein Kernargument. Und inhaltlich habe ich dieses Argument auch schon vorgetragen. Ich glaube, das war sogar die Sendung, äh in der wir irgendwie äh äh die Freiheit statt Angstdemo äh rekapituliert haben, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Da hat er recht. Es gibt Leute, die sind, die sind von existenzieller Sorge, äh getragen und.
Das hat bei der Politik dann alles nichts zu tun.
Mit Netzkritik erstmal nix zu tun. Es gibt ja die Idee der
Pyramide, ne? Und wenn die Menschen sich nicht um äh wenn die Menschen schon Sorge haben müssen ihren Kühlschrank zu füllen, dann ist
Idee, wie sie die Freiheit der äh der des des Landes erhalten können, für sie eine zweitrangige.
Ja, gibt sicherlich auch eine Menge.
Die SPD in den letzten äh zwei Jahrzehnten gespielt hat, äh für die Menschen, die sich jetzt in dieser Situation befinden. Und das ist ein Grund außer scheiß SPD auszutreten. Und die Haltung zur Netzpolitik ist da nun wirklich nicht mehr überraschend.
Ja, unabhängig jetzt davon, was man jetzt über die SPD und ihr äh äh jüngstes Vermächtnis äh denken mag, äh muss ja auch sagen,
Einer der Punkte der Netzpolitik ist ja auch ja, natürlich gibt's da prekäre Situationen auf dem Land. Und wie könnte man die lösen?
Na, wie wär's denn zum Beispiel, das Land mal in die digitale Gesellschaft äh anzubinden und die Möglichkeit
keit zu schaffen, auch da in diesen äh den den Metropolen fern äh Gebieten äh digital arbeiten zu können und da äh genauso ein Business und einen Versand und was nicht alles aufziehen zu können, aber wenn man noch nicht mal in der Lage ist, seine eigene Webseite äh halbwegs im Griff zu behalten,
da man einfach über keine stabilen äh Hochgeschwindigkeitsverbindungen führt, dann kann das halt auch nix werden. Also der Anschluss wird auch gerade in diesen,
meinetwegen prekären oder unterentwickelten Bereichen verloren und es ist ja ein Hauptlied, gerade also diese sogenannte Berliner Intelligenz ja oder wie auch immer, dass da in dem Zusammenhang genannt wurde, äh
setzt sich ja vor allem auch, also es geht ja hier nicht nur um unsere geilen zehn Gigabit äh Anschlüsse,
also auf die wir dann natürlich auf keinen Fall verzichten wollen, sondern es geht genauso gut dadrum, ähm.
Das auch auf dem Land zu haben. Es geht jetzt auch nicht nur nur um Anschlüsse, aber das ist,
also es ist aber auf jeden Fall ein ein Thema, was man miteinander verbinden kann und was auch was miteinander zu tun hat und äh das kam in der Diskussion sicherlich jetzt nicht zur Sprache.
Die SPD davon ausgeht, dass eine Gesellschaft weiterhin irgendwie ähm so der Gestalt sein,
soll das ähm dass irgendwie die Menschen durch.
Ökonomische Betätigung äh ihren und Lebensunterhalt verdienen in was weiß ich, in Angestelltenverhältnissen und irgendwo etwas schaffen, ja. Ähm,
muss sie auch dafür sorgen, dass dem dem dem Umstand Rechnung tragen, dass dieses Internet in Zukunft so gut wie keinen Job der Welt mehr möglich äh äh kein Job der Welt mehr zulassen wird,
Das ist in Zukunft kein Job der Welt mehr ohne Internet geben wird,
ja? Und oder keinen nennenswerten Anteil, ja? Also wir es in in relativ naher Zukunft ein Land ohne vernünftige Internetinfrastruktur nicht mehr äh international.
Nicht so ein Land wie Deutschland,
Ja, also das mag jetzt so nicht äh für alle Länder äh gelten, sicherlich auch nicht für alle Regionen für Deutschland, aber Deutschland an sich ein Land, was sich definiert durch seine Infrastruktur
Also dessen Infrastruktur schon immer die Basis war der wirtschaftlichen äh Kraft diese Infrastruktur muss auch genauso digital
geschaffen werden. Und da ist einfach fünfzig Megabit VDSL von der Telekom bis zwanzig achtzehn ist einfach Visionsarmut pur.
Es gibt noch einen zweiten Punkt, das ist die äh der, sage ich mal, die ähm.
Bildung, der die
Schaffenskraft, die irgendwie Deutschland natürlich auch äh zu einer zu dieser internationalen äh Position verholfen hat, neben natürlich einer geschickten Politik, äh die immer dafür gesorgt hat, dass wir auch äh arme Idioten hatten, die dann am Ende die
ah ich du merkst, wir sind hier im Moll, also ähm.
Wir drehen uns auch um Kreis. Lass uns äh da vorwärts kommen. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt
ganz gut dargestellt. Es gibt einfach äh diese Auseinandersetzungen, die finden weitgehend im Geheimen statt. Äh das Krokodil ist äh langsam unterwegs, äh ja äh regelt sich,
das ist sicherlich wertvoll, das auch weiter zu äh beobachten und ich bin gespannt, was aus dem ganzen Schlamassel so herauskommen wird. Hoffnungsfroh sind wir jetzt nicht unbedingt, aber
wir lassen's ja jetzt auch den Spaß nicht verderben.
Wir werden mal sehen.
So, weitere äh Shopping News. Ja.
Wir finden alles raus. Ja. Alles finden die raus.
Vor allem jetzt so, wo so mäßig äh im Zentrum Berlins auf einmal wirkliche Entdeckungen gemacht werden. Ja, es ist schon äh fantastisch. Man hat dann auch irgendwann mal angefangen.
Dächer zu fotografieren.
Ja, man hat schon vor langer Zeit äh angefangen, dich ja zu fotografieren. Das nennt sich dann äh äh Google Maps.
Ja, hat bloß keiner drauf geguckt, weil ist ja böse.
Du da haben wir auch schon, das da haben wir auch schon immer drauf geguckt. Das ich meine, wir haben doch, selbst hier in den Sendungen gesagt, guck mal auf die anderen Botschaften. So und das hat dann ähm,
Frank Rieger äh mal hat dann den den der hat noch nicht mal Google Maps, der hat Bing Maps benutzt, ja. Der ist auf Bing Maps gegangen und hat gesagt, ach guck mal hier, auf der britischen Botschaft, ein Radom.
Ein Raddom ist eine ähm im Prinzip ein Zelt für Antennen. Ja, aus einem bestimmten Stoff, der dann äh möglichst ähm,
Gute Eigenschaften hat äh für das Durchlassen von ähm,
elektromagnetischen Wellen, in dem äh Spektrum, was da empfangen werden soll ähm und ansonsten eigentlich den dem Zweck erfüllt, die empfindlichen ähm Empfangsanlagen, die das Radom verbirgt vor den Einflüssen der Witterung zu schützen. Oder
vor neugierigen Blicken. Ja. Ja?
Wir hatten das schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen, dass natürlich diese in der äh der Abhöranlage Abhöranlage Teufelsberg ähm diese großen äh Kugeln, die sich dadrauf befinden, sind
Zelte. Die sind auch aus dem Stoff und es gibt auch immer mal wieder irgendein Idioten, der dann äh.
Was rausschneidet.
Ein Stück rausschneidet,
und da das das Ding beschädigt und dann sieht man, dass es Stoff ist, der sehr stark gespannt ist, deswegen halst da drin auch so.
Akustik also.
Muss man muss man mal hingehen. Ähm aber genau, also ein kleines Raddömchen ähm haben die Briten völlig unbemerkt, ja. Ähm ja,
ähm.
Ist das auch nicht so überraschend in dem Sinne als also das eine Botschaft über Kommunikationsanlagen äh verfügt und zwar immer, überall in jedem Land. Das dürfte auch der Bundesregierung nicht entgangen sein. Sie betreibt diese ja auch schon seit fünfzig Jahren in aller Welt.
Ja? Also jede deutsche Botschaft hat selbstverständlich Satellitenkommunikation, weil äh man sich natürlich auf gar keinen Fall äh nur
oder überhaupt auch,
die lokale Infrastruktur verlassen kann, nicht nur jetzt wegen Überwachung, sondern einfach aus äh Zuverlässigkeits und Direktheits äh Gründen. Und äh von daher ist das jetzt auch nicht so überraschend, dass die britische Botschafter auch sowas hat. Das sieht das Teil sieht jetzt sehr ähm
nice aus, wenn man das so anschaut. Das hat so einen gewissen Bedrohlichkeits äh Faktor, sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Wasserturm
aber da ist sicherlich kein Wasser drin und die Briten werden natürlich klar argumentiert, na ja, da sind halt unsere Satellitenschüsseln drin, äh weil wir müssen ja,
kommunizieren, ja? Also wir müssen ja in die Heimat senden können.
Genau. Und weil sie da, ne, weil sie da so ein so einen Heimatsender, Antenne drunter haben, hat der Westerwelle dann den britischen Botschafter auch Brutsch. Den hat Westerwelle, der ja immer noch Außenminister ist, ne. Ähm.
Ja.
Den britischen Botschafter eingeladen.
Geladen oder einen bestellt? Eingeladen nach so.
Eingeladen. Lieber britischer Botschaft.
Um um einige Informationen auszuleiten.
Eingeladen.
Ja um Informationen auszuleiten oder aufzufangen. Vielleicht hat er mit so einem Kescher hinter ihm hergelaufen. Falls irgendwelche Informationen abfallen, dass er die dann auffangen kann.
Ich habe gestern äh es gibt, ich es gibt eine Wikipedia-Seite zu Radom,
ja, wo dann auch nochmal erklärt ist lassen und dann gibt es, da, da, da, da gibt es eine Liste Radoms in Europa,
und dann gibt es da Deutschland und äh da fehlte tatsächlich die britische Botschaft in Berlin, die habe ich mal dazu geschrieben mit dem Vermerk Verwendungszweck unklar, aber offensichtlich.
So, bin mal gespannt, wie lange das da drin bleibt, ja? Also, hier britische, das ist da habe ich beigetragen, so Wikipedia.
Bis jetzt hat das noch keiner wieder rausgenommen, aber ja, also in der in der Liste der deutschen Radobe ist jetzt auch das und ich habe es auch getauft, das Rigaradom, ja?
Das Riegaradom. Ja, völlig unentdeckt.
Alternativ auch äh,
Riga Hanussen äh Radom, weil ja der äh Frank Schirmacher Frank Rieger dann äh auch noch als digitalen Hanussen bezeichnete, weil Frank das äh schon vorher gewusst hat, ja. Na,
ja ist irgendwas, irgendwas Frankfurter Intellektuelles Wort für für Hellseher oder Zukunftsvorhersager oder sowas. Ja,
müssen die ja dann immer. Die müssen ja immer irgendwie äh ähm können ja nicht einfach irgendeinen Satz sagen, da muss ja dann immer noch mitschwingen, dass sie ähm dass sie gebildete sind.
Ähm so. Also auf der britischen Botschaft ist ein Radom. Alles finden die raus.
Als nächstes finden die bestimmt sogar noch raus, dass die Geheimdienste zusammenarbeiten, aber dazu kommen wir später. Ähm denn die eigentliche News dieser dieser Woche war ja, dass ähm.
Ströbele.
Eine coole Sau ist.
Ist echt mal eine geile Sau. Man muss ja echt, vielleicht die Jüngeren Hörerinnen, vielleicht wissen die ja gar nicht, was für eine geile Sau Christian Ströbele ist.
Wer ist eigentlich genau, das kann man ruhig mal betonen.
Christian Ströbele ähm ist,
glaube ich das erste Mal wirklich in Erscheinung getreten als äh Anwalt der RAF.
Hans-Christian Strupp.
Hans-Christian äh ist erstmals in Erscheinung getreten als ähm Anwalt der RAF zusammen glaube ich, wer war noch die,
Chili und der Croissant, Claus Croissant, das war das Anwalts äh die Anwaltskanzlei, bei der die immer waren, bei der die beide, glaube ich, angestellt waren,
Horst Maler war auch noch Raf-Anwalt, also die aus äh Rafanwelten ist echt äh die Rafa-Anwälter im illustre Karrieren äh.
Auch unterschiedlicher kaum sein können,
also ne, also von Innenminister zu äh Nazi äh alles äh drin. Nur Ströbele ist in gewisser Hinsicht
sei deinem Pfad da eigentlich immer treu geblieben und hat immer mit einer klar linken Positionierung auch immer als Aufklärer,
gearbeitet.
Ist übrigens mein Wahlkreis, Hans-Christian Ströbele.
Ja, meiner auch.
Echt?
Prenzlauer Berg Ost. Das ist bei äh Bundeswahlen. Reicht das hier noch mit rein?
Okay, weil eine ist das ja Friedrichshain Kreuzberg.
Und Prenzlauer Bergost. Also von daher.
Okay, alles klar. Ich dachte Prenzlauer Berg, äh Ost wäre irgendwie.
Prenzlberg ist gar nicht so schlecht, wie man manchmal meinen möchte.
Hans-Christian Strobele, also eine.
Mitbegründer der Grünen in Berlin, also der alternativen Linien, der TAZ. Dann war er im Bundestag und äh,
Irgendwann so in den letzten Jahren war er dann bei den Grünen nicht mehr ganz so wohl gelitten, wo sich die ganzen Grünen so ein bisschen nach rechts äh äh bewegt haben
da war dann halt eher so als äh terrible, der auch irgendwie äh komischerweise immer nicht bereit war, von seinen Prinzipien abzurücken, ja? Ähm.
Ja, das das stimmt.
Wäre er fast mal komplett rausgekickt worden und hat dann hier dieses Wunder äh vollbracht, der erste Direktkandidat der Grünen zu sein, der es in den Bundestag geschafft hat, also er ist der erste Grüne, der wirklich seinen eigenen Wahlkreis gewonnen hat und,
quasi als stärkste oder ist er nicht sogar noch der einzige.
Aber der einzige ist, aber ich weiß, dass er der einzige ist, der mit so einer absoluten ähm äh mit mit so einer absoluten mehr,
nicht absolut mit einer, mit einem absoluten Vorsprung, garantiert immer diesen Wahlkreis bekommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob er der einzige ist, das kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Ich glaube, er war der Erste. Nom.
So
Ich bin mir relativ, ich wollte jetzt nur nochmal kurz gucken, also Klaus Croissant, Kurt Kröne war Volt, Hans-Christian Ströbele waren dann so die Verteidiger von Andreas Barer.
Und so weiter. Also äh genau, der müsste müsste ich weiß nicht, ob er in der Kanzlei von Croissant war, aber ich weiß, dass es so der um den Croissant äh bewegt sich so diese ganzen Rafanwälder. Ähm,
Christian Ströbele, Direktkandidat, inzwischen schon weit über siebzig und ähm.
Ein bisschen leise.
Ja. Kein bisschen leise kann man sagen. Ich meine, er ist ein bisschen isoliert und das ist auch das, was du gerade ansprachst. Er ist ähm.
Die Grünen halten sich denen so ein bisschen, ne, dann ist er da mit seiner äh äh immer mit einem roten Schal, äh dann wird er immer mit einer Sonnenblume fotografiert. Ist so ein bisschen so ein.
Wie er im Buche steht.
Ja, so genau, der das ist so ein grünen Fossil, den können die sich leisten
weil er selbst innerhalb der Partei keine Mehrheit hat und der kann sich das dann auch leisten bei den äh bei den Einsätzen der Bundeswehr, im äh im Ausland. Als einziger Grüner dann noch dagegen ähm,
zu zu stimmen, weil er irgendwie keine,
weil er den selbst, weil er den den wirklichen äh der wirklichen Führungsregel der Grünen da einfach nicht mehr gefährlich wird. So. Ne, das heißt, er hat da auch so auch ein bisschen Narrenfreiheit. Und diese Narrenfreiheit hat er genutzt und ist einfach mal,
nach Russland geflogen.
Man muss noch eins sagen, was wir nicht gesagt haben. Er ist auch das älteste Dienstälteste.
Im Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium.
Genau und dieses parlamentarische Kontrollgrößen ist das Gremium, was halt noch am meisten Informationen,
Erhält von den Geheimdiensten in Deutschland. Das ist sozusagen der Teil, der äh des Bundestags, der,
ja, die Geheimdienste kontrolliert ist, ja, also steht zumindest drauf, ja, das kann man ähm
in Zweifel ziehen, dass da viel Kontrolle ausgeübt wird, weil leider eben diese Sitzung natürlich auch alle nicht öffentlich sind. Und darüber darf auch nicht
werden, also Ströbele kann nicht äh in die Öffentlichkeit gehen und sagen, das und das wurde hier uns erzählt, sondern er kann nur sagen, naja, ich.
Ziehe folgende Schlüsse aus dem, was mir gesagt wurde. Und er war natürlich von Anfang an äh auch Förderer der Idee Edward Snoden,
einzuladen als Zeuge, er ist sicherlich auch ein Anhänger der Idee ihm Asyl zu bewähren in Deutschland und
Argumentation, naja, der Typ sitzt da jetzt irgendwie. Äh ihr ihr wollt die ganze Zeit aufklären, dann äh klärt doch mal auf, äh holt euch doch einfach mal den Typen ran, der da am meisten drüber weiß, ja, der kann euch sicherlich weiterhelfen
wo ja die deutsche Bundesregierung aus äh teilweise verständlichen und teilweise unverständlichen Gründen halt rumeiert,
Jetzt ist immer wieder Kragen geplatzt. Er hatte dann wohl schon länger äh probiert, da mal seiner äh also Snodens habhaft äh zu werden oder zumindest in Kontakt zu treten,
Kurzfristig berichtete er, seien diese Kontakte halt wieder aufgewärmt worden, wodurch auch immer das äh induziert wurde und dann
geschah es, Hans-Christian Ströbele fliegt nach Moskau und führt äh begleitet von zwei Journalisten vom Spiegel und vom,
NDR.
Ich habe mir nur gemerkt, dass der Maskolo dabei war und ich hatte eigentlich gehofft, dass der Maskolo jetzt endlich mal irgendwie eine andere Karriere verfolgt, aber.
Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall die drei waren halt da und haben sich irgendwie drei Stunden mit Snowden direkt getroffen und unterhalten und,
sichtlich genossen, dann vor den Medien zu stehen und darüber zu berichten.
Ich glaube, am meisten wird er genossen haben, dass er dann auf äh CNN äh mit der Bauchbinde äh deutscher Außenminister, ja. Ich meine, naheliegend, oder?
Ja, irgendwie schon.
Vermuten, dass irgendein Hanse aus dem Bundestag den den,
Ne, also ich meine, da wirst du sehen, wahrscheinlich werden die nicht, wenn die nicht gewusst hätten, dass die deutsche Kanzlerin eine Frau ist, hätten die wahrscheinlich Kanzler dran geschrieben. Also haben die gesagt, ja.
Ja natürlich, du würdest doch nicht erwarten, dass dass es dass es dass die gesamte Regierung irgendwie,
Da rumhängt und ein einzelner eine einzelne Koryphäe ähm dann da äh anreist mit einem roten Schal,
So, natürlich denkst du, dass da irgendwie Minister ist und dann leider töten muss, wo der Außenminister sein,
Ja, also kann ich kann ich, kann ich gut verstehen, dass sie ähm dass sie diesen Fehler gemacht haben oder vielleicht auch absichtlich da Guido Westerwelle, mit dem sie ja auch irgendwie vorher mal gesprochen hatten,
Ähm einen auswischen wollten. Ströbele besucht Snowden. SNON hat jetzt äh das die Randmeldung in Russland einen Job,
als äh Daten für Datenschutzbeauftragter oder Datenschutz zuständiger bei einer großen russischen Webseite und Strömer hat dann einen kleinen Brief mitgebracht
und am gestrigen Mittwoch dann im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium erzählt,
und was er eigentlich sagt oder was so die die Botschaft war, die Ströbele mitbrachte war, naja, der will nicht in Moskau befragt werden, sondern er will Asyl oder Aufenthaltsrecht bekommen und dann Aussagen.
Und da hat er natürlich äh der Ströbele jetzt, der äh der Bundesregierung
schönes Ei gelegt, beziehungsweise na ja, ein Ei, was die Bundesregierung dann äh
wieder will ich entgegennahm und sagte Friedrich da musste dann irgendwie unter dem Druck der Presse dann irgendwie sagen ja man könnte ja mal wir prüfen jetzt schon ob wir den nicht irgendwie befragen können aber,
dass in Deutschland zu machen können wir eigentlich schon jetzt ausschließen, weil wir die das transatlantische Verhältnis dadurch natürlich sehr stark belasten würden und das äh
können wir natürlich nicht machen, aber wir prüfen, ob wir nicht eventuell in äh in Moskau ähm
befragen können. Und das in einer Woche, in der ich denke, der äh Spiegeltitel in dieser Woche ist, Asyl für Snowden Ausrufezeichen. Ich meine also äh,
Also der Spiegel ja irgendwie noch wie gesagt nach dem Maskoll oder weg ist.
Also der Ex-Chefredakteur Chefredakteur des Spiegels.
Seitdem der da weg ist, äh hat der Spiegel ja irgendwie eine eine zweite Blüte. Er musste ja erst irgendwie Stefan und den Maskolo irgendwie überleben, aber im Moment ähm,
gibt es glaube ich so einen, so einen journalistisches Revival des Spiegels.
Jeden Fall vom Spiegel online.
Dafür war der Maskott aber gar nicht zuständig. Egal, andere Sachen.
Nö, aber das merkt man, also ich meine.
Klar, sie haben ja jetzt auch ein Thema, aber der Spiegel mit einer für ihn eigentlich unverhältnismäßig,
Nee, ist Quatsch. Das ist mit Spiegel nicht unverhältnismäßig reißerisch als Titel. Also die Forderung, Asyl fürs Norden, äh äh ist offen, ist auf dem
Titelbild des Spiegels und in einer solchen äh Zeit stellt sich der ähm der Friedrich dran weiterhin äh vor die Presse und sagt, ja also ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Asyl für diesen Menschen
ähm schließen wir aus. Und dann gibt's ein Interview mit äh Lon Snowden, dem
dem Vater von von AdWords Norden, der dann auch sagte, also naja, äh nach, nach Deutschland zu gehen oder dort Asyl irgendwie zu beantragen, davon kann ich meinem Sohn ja nur abraten, ähm,
Denn wird die Regierung, hat ja viele Monate äh geschwiegen, bis es und erst irgendwie den Arsch hochbekommen, als irgendwie das Privathandy der Kanzlerin betroffen war. Ähm denen es nicht zu trauen. Und.
Das ist aber auch der selbe Vater, der äh vorher der Meinung war, der sollte doch wieder in die USA zurückkehren. Also,
der scheint mir auch noch leichte Wandlung im Rahmen. Also am Anfang ist ja, glaube ich, noch von anderen Prämissen ausgegangen. Vielleicht hat das mittlerweile auch verstanden.
Erscheint zwischen verstanden zu haben und ähm.
Jetzt habe ich kurz den Faden verloren. Ja, also deutsche Regierung will also irgendwie mal was von dem Wissen. Aber irgendwie ist nicht bereit dafür, den Menschen irgendwie äh entgegenzukommen und das natürlich.
Man stelle sich jetzt mal vor, sie würden ihn wirklich hierher äh holen. Und ihm was weiß ich, zusichern.
Sie können dem keine Sicherheit ähm sie können ihm keine Sicherheit bieten.
Ja eben. Stell dir mal vor, sie würden ihm irgendwas zusichern. Und dann kommt der an und dann setzen sie ihn einfach gleich in die nächste United-Maschine und fliegen ihn in die USA. Was wäre dann?
Das wäre dann das wäre wenigstens mal ehrlich, aber der Umgang, also der.
Ja, aber ich meine, kann man das ausschließen.
Nein, aber das muss man wenigstens mal sagen. Der Umgang äh also zu sagen.
Wir wollen das transatlantische Verhältnis nicht dadurch ähm strapazieren, dass wir dem Kronzeugen eines Spionageangriffs auf uns Asyl gewähren.
Während ein anderes Land das tut, wenn ein anderes Land dem Asyl gewährt und sagt, hier bumm. Ja, machen wir. Dieser Umgang ist äh,
finde ich einerseits beschämend und einerseits beängstigend. Beängstigend ist er deshalb, weil du siehst, okay, krass, so stark hat Amerika irgendwie Deutschland in der Tasche, dass Deutschland sich nicht,
das nicht trauen kann. Und erstaunlicherweise, da muss ich dann mal meine Fähigkeiten betonen,
Es hat sich in dieser ganzen Lage eigentlich nichts geändert. Wir kriegen nur neue Informationen. Das Bild bleibt aber das Gleiche. Und zwar habe ich irgendwie in einer der ersten Logbuch Netzpolitiksendungen
ähm die wir zu dem Thema hatten, gesagt. Die Deutschen werden dahin gehen und dann werden die Amerikaner den sagen, haltet die Fresse.
Und dann wird diese Sache irgendwie unbequem ausgesessen und genau das passiert jetzt. Deutschland sind da auf eine auf eine beängstigende Weise äh die Hände gebunden,
und es ist wirklich erbärmlich, sich das anzuschauen. Und das Problem ist, dass ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass wenn ich äh was weiß ich, wenn es in meiner Macht lege und ich die Informationen hätte, die die Bundesregierung hat, dass ich auch nicht,
dass ich auch sagen müsste, den kann ich nicht hierhin holen. Aber ich glaube, dass oder ich würde hoffen, dass sich dann wenigstens so ehrlich wäre, vor die Presse zu treten, zu sagen,
Ich würde gerne, aber wenn ich den hier hinhole, kann ich nicht für die Sicherheit von diesen Menschen garantieren. Und ich ich kann das, ich kann dem nicht in die, ich kann dem nicht in die Sicherheit.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt im Prinzip schon fast schon im nächsten äh Blog.
Nee, ich würde noch äh.
Sollten wir die Geschichte nochmal kurz äh abschließen.
Was ist denn ja du meinst es dann, dass dann am Ende Springer noch gegen den Ströbele schießt in der Welt oder oder was ist der.
Auch immer jetzt noch dazu zu sagen ist, weil wenn ich jetzt aushole, dann sind wir voll im nächsten Thema und dann wird alles durcheinander.
Springer kommuniziert, kombinierte dann noch messerscharf, dass der äh russische Geheimdienst FSB da wohl äh mit drinsteckt, dass der Ströbele den äh Snowden besucht hat. Und da kann man nur sagen
meine Güte, das ist ja echt mal schlau, dass sie dass sie dass sie sowas merken,
dass sie das eventuell man mit mit dem russischen Geheimdienst reden muss, bevor man es schafft
äh diesen Menschen zu treffen. Und dass die äh also benahm dann Bezug auf die Geschichte, dass der Ströbel ja in einem abgedunkelten Van irgendwie abgeholt wurde und dann zu Snowden gefahren wurde. Natürlich spricht Peter, dass die russische Regierung mit und natürlich spielt da äh der russische Geheimdienst mit, wenn es darum geht,
diesen Menschen zu treffen.
Ja und äh ich denke, Putin reibt sich ohnehin kräftig die Hände, weil äh jetzt sozusagen da so äh Hardcore-Verbündete äh der USA
Wasser, so äh so ein bisschen da durcheinander zu äh oder auseinanderzutreiben
und da äh Neid, Missgunst, Zwietracht und was nicht alles noch zu sehen, das passt ihnen natürlich völlig ins Programm. Ja, also Putin hat äh im Prinzip,
riesen,
Vorteil davon auf der einen Seite profitiert da so bisschen so der Asylgeber zu sein von einer äh Person, die äh auf dem Planeten eine gewisse Popularität hat mit Ausnahme bei den USA, ja. Aber eben auch in Teilen der USA.
Kann man eigentlich von den Problemen, die die Russland halt gar nicht ablenken?
Nebenbei etabliert er sozusagen genau dasselbe System, was Snowden in den USA äh kritisiert, aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema,
Und jetzt äh läuft halt auch alles noch äh zwischen Deutschland und den USA, ne.
Ich glaube, man muss einfach wissen oder mein Eindruck ist, dass das in Russland, dass man in Russland da einfach auch offener, zynisch sein kann.
Als Politiker. Also zu sagen, ja also das halt auch offener zu sehen, so das ist klar, das ist ein der das ist ein.
Also ich würde jetzt überhaupt gar keine Mutmaßungen darüber anstellen, was man in Russland als Politiker tun kann oder nicht tun kann. Ich glaube, so viel ist das jetzt äh nicht. Lassen sie diesen Bock äh hiermit äh abschließen. Man kann äh,
quasi zum nächsten Teil äh überleiten, ja. Äh es sind ja jetzt auch verschiedene Dokumente äh aufgetreten, die eben auch eine Zusammenarbeit der Dienste äh auf ein
ja, in ein anderes Licht ähm stellen und für meinen Geschmack zeichnet sich hier immer weiter ab.
Dass das eigentliche Problem hier ist, nicht die Amerikaner spendieren die Deutschen aus, die Deutschen tun's nicht ausreichend oder so,
all diese Meldungen der letzten
Wochen und Monate, die sie auch immer nicht sich so richtig zusammenaddieren ließen mit wo haben denn die Amerikaner diese Abhör äh Zahlen in Frankreich und in Deutschland erreicht? Ja und äh unser Innenminister eiert rum und sagte, hat der BND aufgefangen und so weiter, als irgendwie man sie fallen gelassen hat? Also da wird
viel um den heißen Brei herumgeredet und ich denke die Auflösung des Ganzen kann eigentlich nur dadrin zu sehen sein,
Dass wir es einfach bei den Geheimdiensten hier äh.
Dass hier eine internationale Kooperation auf Geheimdienstebene stattfindet und für meinen Geschmack.
Sich in der ganzen Reaktion der Bundesregierung und auch der Reaktion aller anderen Regierungen immer wieder ab, dieses,
Wir lassen euch uns gerne irgendwie schlagen, aber wir werden irgendwie äh deshalb vor allem nichts tun, weil dann einfach herauskäme,
dass wir alle in einem Boot sitzen,
Das ist nicht die böse NSA ist, die uns jetzt hier arme Deutschen überwacht, sondern das sind einfach geheime Kooperationsvereinbarungen,
Gibst du mir zeigst du mir deins, zeige ich dir meins und äh so läuft der Hase und äh je nachdem
wie willig man sich da äh gibt und wie viel man zu bieten hat. Taucht man in so einer
Hierarchie äh auf und die Top äh Hierarchie, also der Präsidentenposten, der ist halt für die USA reserviert. Dann gibt's so die erste Ministerregier, das sind diese fünf Augen, ja?
Offensichtlich gibt es ja jetzt noch einen neuen Augen und vierzehn Augen äh Level, wo dann äh Deutschland, glaube ich, eher im untersten Bereich mitspielen darf, weil eigentlich traut ihnen dann wahrscheinlich am Ende doch keiner so richtig.
Ähm ja, das ist so mal jetzt grob das, was ich sagen würde.
Der Eindruck, den man hat, ist.
Sich hier abzeichnet.
Was hier, was sich hier nach und nach irgendwie zu Tage kommt, es ist nicht die USA äh gegen die anderen Länder,
es ist die Regierungen gegen die Bevölkerungen oder vielleicht sogar noch äh noch krasser, die Geheimdienste gegen,
die Bevölkerungen. Ja, also die Geheimdienste scheinen verstanden zu haben, dass sie äh natürlich irgendwie ihrer äh ihrem Herkunftsstaat irgendwie eine gewisse Solidarität schulden. Aber natürlich auch noch sehr viel in
interessantes äh herausfinden können
und auch sehr viel Nützliches herausfinden können, wenn sie sich mit anderen verbünden. Auch das haben wir ja schon, war, glaube ich, in der gleichen Sendung angesprochen, dass die Geheimdienste natürlich kooperieren, gleichzeitig im Rahmen dieser Kooperation aber eben auch darauf achten müssen, dass sie,
für sich etwas Sinnvolles gewinnen. Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Zur die Lösung in diesem gesamten Spionage USA Deutschland-Konflikt, die sich da jetzt abzeichnet, ist ja ein,
Ein Abkommen über die Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit. Und die USA bieten jetzt an, also als Konsequenz all dessen, was wir in den letzten Monaten äh erlebt haben, bieten die USA an.
Ein schriftlich dokumentierten Verzicht auf Industriespionage.
Und eine bessere, geheimdienstliche Zusammenarbeit.
Freuen.
Eine bessere, geheimnisliche Zusammenarbeit. Aber, ob man das jetzt so macht, das kommt natürlich auch auf den Umgang mit Snowden an und da schließt sich der Kreis der heutigen Sendung,
Das ist ganz klar, das können wir uns abschminken, wenn wir den Snowden irgendwie hier ins Land holen.
Fliegt Deutschland aus allen Geheimdienstlichen Zusammenarbeits äh ebenen raus.
Noch ein Rad um.
Und dann wird das irgendwie nix mehr mit der internationalen Bedeutung.
Dann wird das auch nichts mehr mit. Äh dann werden natürlich auch dann gibt's halt demnächst keine äh keine äh mehr, beziehungsweise deutsche Autos.
Aber ich meine schriftlicher Verzicht auf Industriespionage ist wirklich extrem lächerlich und äh.
Aber das es kommt, es wird ja noch besser. Also das ist das, was jetzt irgendwie das ist das, was auf der Regierungsebene jetzt gerade äh Fazit und Verhandlungsstand aus diesen Enthüllungen ist. Nichts, nichts anderes, diese beiden Dinge. Und.
Deshalb geschah es jetzt am Montag, dass ne jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt ja noch der Hammer. Gerhard Schindler vom BND,
Hans-Georg Maaßen vom äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz reisten jetzt in die USA,
Um dort zu treffen, den NSA-Chef Kiew Alexander und den US-Geheimdienstdirektor James Klepper.
Also er ist nicht vom, nicht nur vom BNDAs, der Präsident des BND, ja?
Achso, ja, natürlich, natürlich, Präsident des BND und der Hans-Georg Maaßen ist auch der Präsident,
die Chefs. Das heißt, die deutschen Geheimdienstchefs fliegen jetzt in die USA und treffen sich mit dem NSA-Direktor und dem Geheimdienstdirektor.
Und die werden jetzt treffen. Eine Vereinbarung auf Arbeitsebene, die eventuell später auf Regierungsebene gehoben werden könnte.
Das ist das ist das sagt echt eine Menge aus. So, ja also die Geheimdienste einigen sich jetzt mal da drauf, was die Regierungen dann später zu tun haben.
Die Geheimdienste, naja, die Regierungen spielen doch eh irgendwo da.
Ja, aber eigentlich müsste sich ja äh Obama mit Merkel äh treffen und äh eine auf Regierungsebene etwas vereinbaren, was dann später vielleicht auch die Arbeitsebene bei den Geheimdiensten sein können.
Genau. Und genau das passiert jetzt nicht. Genau das passiert jetzt nicht.
Das ist echt cool.
So, das heißt, die Geheimdienste machen das jetzt unter sich aus. Und da werden Leute am Tisch sitzen, die sich sagen, ey, Scheiße.
Das mit dem Snowden müssen die, da werden Leute am Tisch sitzen, werden vier Personen an einem Tisch sitzen, die alle sich nicht sehnlicher wünschen, als diese Ganzes, diesen Snowden, Albtraum, irgendwie unbeschadet zu überstehen.
Für das, was sie irgendwie in in dem Laufe ihrer Karriere da an geheimdienstlicher ähm die Infrastruktur aufge.
Er ist die größte Bedrohung für das System der Geheimdienste ever.
Und äh sie haben offensichtlich allein schon aus dem, was bisher herausgekommen ist, schon eine Menge äh Schaden genommen, das ist ja auch klar, dieser Schaden lässt sich auch beziffern, er lässt sich äh,
zusammenrechnen, ist aber auch vor allem ein, ein Ansehensverlust und ich glaube, das ist.
Fast noch mit das Wichtigste und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie bereit sind, gerade einfach alles,
tun. Ich meine, das haben wir ja schon gesehen, als es noch noch noch irgendwie so aussah, als ob Snowden,
Reisen würde, ja, dass dann sogar Präsidentenmaschinen gegroundet werden, das sagt eigentlich schon alles aus, ja, also da ist man einfach bereit, sämtliche internationale Gepflogenheiten einfach zu ignorieren,
äh sie ist nichts mehr heilig in in diesem Fall. Also es gibt einfach denen scheißegal.
Was irgendwie ist und was irgendwie geht und was von UN Resolutionen äh oder welchen Vereinbarungen, auf welchem Wisch auch das immer geschrieben ist, welchem Klo dieser Zettel hängt, ist denen scheißegal
sie werden einfach,
Alles probieren. Von daher wird es sehr spannend äh sein, zu sehen, wie äh sich die Aufenthalt von Snowden in Zukunft noch äh weiter äh entwickeln wird
Ich vermute mal, es ist tendenziell, wenn sich kein Land findet, was ihm ausreichend Schutz gewähren kann, dann äh wird eher Russland nochmal dieses Asyl verlängern
weil sie werden ihn sicherlich nicht einfach Preis geben,
Dafür ist der Spaß viel zu groß, ja. Ähm und äh Länder wie Equador, die ihn wohl gerne äh aufnehmen würden,
bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob die stark genug sind, äh gegen diese Energie vorzugehen, weil die sich halt also das einfach Hubschraubereinsatz äh vorprogrammiert.
Geheimdienste sind ja jetzt auch nicht rachsüchtig, ja? Also ich meine, in einem Jahr wird er, wird der Norden wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht mehr äh nichts mehr in der Hand haben, um irgendwas äh platt zu machen. Der hat dann seinen äh seinen Platz in der Geschichte. Äh wir werden's sehen, ja. Aber,
das eigentlich erstaunliche ist hier wirklich.
Er könnte aber auch zu einem Proxi künftiger äh Whistleblower werden.
Klar, der hat lass uns da jetzt erstmal nicht drüber spekulieren, was ich, was ich spannend finde, ist sogar du sagst so, da ist nichts mehr heilig. Ähm ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, was das Bild, was ich da sehe, ist eher, da war nie was heilig.
Ja ja, aber jetzt ist aber auch nichts mehr heilig, was äh also jetzt äh scheut man sich noch nicht mal mehr um die Außenwirkung. Ja, also so was wie.
Ja genau, mein Mann ist jetzt so, man ist jetzt an der, man ist an die Wand,
Wir müssen jetzt, jetzt geht's einfach um alles,
Jetzt können wir uns nicht mehr hier irgendein Puppentheater leisten. Jetzt müssen wir wirklich äh jetzt müssen wir wirklich einfach durchziehen. So und da kommt jetzt natürlich sehr viel zu Tage und äh ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich das schon äh,
sehr, sehr beängstigend finde und dass mich das auch auf einen ähm auf einen.
Auf ein Paranoia Level hebt, was die Geheim.
Man sich nicht gerne befindet.
Ja
klar, also wo ich mein, irgendwann war ich auch an dem Punkt, äh ich meine, wir haben alle unser paar neue Level, wir haben alle die Leute, die da seit Jahren drüber reden, ne, also Andi Müller ist ja insbesondere einer, den wir da immer wieder nennen, der mit dem man, mit dem ich mich häufiger über solche Themen unterhalten habe
wo ich dann auch immer sage, okay, bis zum gewissen Punkt gehe ich bei dem mit und dann irgendwann kommt so der Punkt, wo ich sage, so ja, jetzt äh reden wir von in zehn Jahren,
Da waren dann diese, da denkt man, ja, da hat er sicherlich seherische Fähigkeiten, die auch äh eine geschlossene Argumentation sind, aber da sehe ich jetzt irgendwie noch ähm,
eine Option für mich als politisch aktiven Menschen dieser dieser Dystopie entgegen zu wirken. Und das scheint inzwischen äh schon längst.
Es verbraucht sich. Also das ist wirklich äh das Problem, man hat eher so das Gefühl, es ist nicht eine Vision von in zehn Jahren vielleicht, sondern sieht halt eher schon so aus, als ob's schon seit zehn Jahren so ist. Und es ist wirklich,
beunruhigen, ne? Besonders beunruhigend finde ich ja auch die ähm,
Die Rolle der Briten äh an der Stelle, weil äh sich auf der einen Seite, also ich meine, so äh ja der von äh,
Innenminister auch mal gerne äh zitierte Anti-Amerikanismus.
Ja auch nicht so, dass es denen nicht gebe, ja? Und äh da macht es sich auch für die Öffentlichkeit immer leicht, so auf die NSA einzuschlagen und wenn man jetzt so mal so den derzeitigen äh äh Humor in den öffentlichen Medien gestern
Irgendwie so eine komische Lanzgesprächsrunde irgendwie im Fernsehen an mir vorbei, wo sie dann auch äh ganz herzlich sogar mit Edmund Stoiber in der Runde irgendwie äh so über NSA, Abhör äh Sachen herumwitzelten,
Ja, also das ist jetzt sozusagen das ist jetzt so normal, dass man das macht, ja?
Vielleicht liegt's aber an der komischen Abkürzung, aber über diesen GCHQ redet halt in demselben Maße äh so noch keiner und das äh Britannien eben einfach mal ein Land ist, was äh Teil der Europäischen Union ist
finde ich eben an der Stelle einfach nochmal ähm besonders problematisch, äh nicht so sehr, weil man jetzt,
vertraglich wirtschaftlich äh mit dem Land verbunden ist
das auch, sondern weil eben die Europäische Union sich ja auch als Wertegemeinschaft versteht. Und dass einfach die Werte, die an der Stelle äh dort zum Ausdruck kommen, so eben einfach überhaupt nicht passen. Immer in dem Moment, wo man auch feststellen wird, vermutlich,
Das ist auch der BND genauso,
Wenig äh ernst nimmt, ja, wie die Briten, ja, dann ist es vielleicht auch schon wieder egal. Trotz alledem ähm,
ist es einfach schon sehr frech.
Stellt sich raus GCHQ hat ja das die Zusammenarbeit mit dem BND auch schon seit vielen Jahren aktiv
und ein äh Dokument aus dem Besitz von Snowden
ist dann auch ein Bericht über die Zusammenarbeit mit den verschiedenen Ländern und das schreiben sie also schreibt ja? Also die wo wir immer sagten oh die Gemeinden die auf unseren Unterseekabeln.
Pora und.
Prora und so machen, ne? Die sagen, das ist jetzt, glaube ich, zweitausendacht datiert das Dokument. Ähm der deutsche Dienst kann deutlich mehr Daten aus Internetleitungen abfischen als äh wir es können?
Mit unserem Tempora, der BND hat ein gewaltiges technisches Potential und einen guten Zugang zum Herzen des Internets,
Das haben die schon vor Jahren über den Deutschen Geheimdienst gesagt.
Oh, das habe ich noch nicht gelesen. Zugang zum Herz des Internets.
Na ja, die Six, einer der größeren.
Ja. Mhm. Verstehe. Hm.
Ich habe nix mehr zu sagen.
Ja, ich mir fällt auch jetzt auch nichts mehr ein. Ja, äh liebe Zuhörer, ja, ihr die ihr euch äh im Herz des Internets aufhaltet.
Jürbin Watch. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, oder? Linus? Ja. Alles klar. Dann tschüss.
Tschau.